( intro music )
Erika Larsen:
The horse is this way
to connect people with their
dreams for the future
with their land,
with their culture,
with what made them
most proud...
connected them
with their ancestors...
and to a history that wasn't
so long ago for them.
( applause )
The Native Americans had...
what many consider,
a short, but very intense
200-year relationship
with the horse,
which transformed their culture.
This might have existed,
the dates change a bit,
between the late 1600s until
the late 1800s.
But I was sent to look
at the modern day culture.
Look at the horse
and how it existed today...
what was this relationship,
what did it mean to people.
They showed me first
it was a very deep
spiritual connection.
The horse represented respect,
pride, generosity,
strength, medicine, healing.
I saw the horse
as a symbol of pride.
It was used in pageantry,
in parades, and in racing.
And it was always adorned
with the family or a tribe's
best accoutrements.
This regalia everyone was
so proud to display,
who they were
and who their family was
through the horse.
I also saw it is a means of
an economic way of life.
A lot of families I met,
got their children into rodeo,
and these children are
getting full rides
to college because of rodeo,
because of their relationship
to the horse.
But most important for me, or
what I saw as most profound, is
the horse was this way
to connect people
with their ancestors,
with their land,
with their culture,
with what made them
most proud,
connected them with their
dreams for the future.
'The Return Of The Native.'
Every tribe I met said
the horse has always
been here.
To be honest, I didn't know
what they meant by that.
Because to me,
the horse came in 1400s.
They said, 'No. The horse
has always been here.'
The horse had been here
10 million years ago.
It moved its way east
before becoming extinct
in the Americas,
and did come back
with Christopher Columbus
on his second journey.
What I wanted to do is,
follow this path a little bit.
So, I started in the south
in Navajo Nation,
where I met Jones Benally.
And Jones is a medicine man
and he works
in tribal health care.
And he works along,
what he calls,
'Western medicine.'
But most of the patients
that come to him for help,
gift him horses, still today...
in exchange
for his services.
And a lot of these horses
that are given to him are...
what are considered green,
or they haven't been ridden
or not ridden very much.
And his son Clayson,
works with these horses.
Many of you here
might have heard
what is called
'breaking a horse.'
But Clayson said to me,
we don't break horses.
He says,
'I have no interest in
breaking the spirit
of a horse.'
He said,
'I need to understand a horse
to get to know the horse and
that's when I can ride a horse.'
And he says, 'we employ...'
if he wants to say,
that way 'more gentler means.'
Clayson said to me,
'when I can kneel down,
and a horse can feel
my breath, and I feel his,
that's when I've built the bond
with the horse,
that's when I can ride him,
and that horse
is part of me forever
and I'm part of him.'
Then I moved my way
north a bit
and I saw the Nez Perce horse
or the Appaloosa.
Also at the Nez Perce land,
I met Rosa and Jon Yearout.
They have a program called
the Nez Perce Appaloosa
Horse Club.
And it is to get youth,
tribal youth, involved
with the horse.
Because to them, they believe
that when the youth become
involved in the horse,
they become involved
in their culture,
they become involved with
understanding their history,
they understand
their land more
and they understand
themselves more.
And Brooke Taylor,
she is sixteen,
she said to me,
'when I ride a horse...
( sobbing )
and I walk the trail
that my ancestors did...
I feel their suffering and
I know that's why
I'm standing here today.'
She says, 'that's why I do this.
That's why I'm connected
to the horse.
I understand my people
and my land
more than ever before.'
And the horse mask.
From the Nez Perce,
I was definitely in awe of
how they dressed their horses
and I wanted to explore
that a little bit more.
And the horse mask was used
for many reasons,
it is used in battle
to intimidate an opponent.
Later it was used in hunting,
sometimes it could be
a mask of a buffalo
or the animal
that they were hunting...
not so much to intimidate
the animal, but to,
to take the power
of that animal
and try to understand it
and to be able to
have a good harvest.
I met a young boy
named Adam Swetus
and he wanted to show me
his horse.
And when I got there,
he had tied the end up
and put a hand print on it.
I had seen the hand prints
and different types of symbols
on horses and other places
and it meant something
different to everyone.
To Adam, he said,
'the handprint meant
ownership.'
And what he meant by
ownership, is he means that,
this bond... horse,
belongs to me,
he goes... but it also belongs
to my family.
And he thought a little more
and he said,
'it belongs to my tribe.'
He said,
'it belongs to my people.'
So, very interesting idea
of what is ownership.
I also met Katie Harris.
She is Umatilla,
Nez Perce, and Cayuse.
And she is involved
in the Indian pageantry
and she showed me that
it was a lot more than beauty.
She said, 'for me to participate
in these pageants,'
She said, 'I have to have
the knowledge of my language,
I have to have a knowledge of
my culture,' and she goes,
'most importantly,
the knowledge of my
'immediate family,
my grandmother did this.
'I wanted to walk in the
footsteps of my grandmother
and understood
why she did this
and what she felt.'
And of course, I went to
Crow Fair.
You can't... you want to learn
something about the horse
and not go to Crow Fair.
And at Crow Fair
I heard a very similar thing.
That when we are on a horse
and we are wearing this,
we are not in museum.
It's not dead, it's living,
and that's why we do this.
I was able to make some video,
and you can hear
the voice of
Jade Broncho,
he is Shoshone-Bannock.
And he is going to tell us
what the horse means to him
and to his culture.
( Native American singing )
These horses,
they are everything to us.
They tell you when the season
is going to change...
storm is coming.
When bad people are around,
good people are around.
They are teachers,
someone you can talk to...
your best friend,
and some days,
he's your only friend.
When you are feeling bad,
they are there.
They take care of you,
even when you don't know how.
They don't...
they don't judge you.
All they want is
to be loved by you.
( laughter )
They protect the little kids
because they are still innocent.
But at the same time,
they are just as naughty.
( crowd cheering )
A part of them becomes you
and you become part of them.
It's a strong bond
that can't break.
( Native American singing )
I'll continue on...
this is Phillip Whiteman.
What I found most interesting
and important about Phillip
is his work with youth.
He and his wife,
Lynette Two Bulls,
hold a program
on their ranch,
on their home in Lame Deer,
he's Northern Cheyenne.
And he said to me
'when I watch
these little kids
feed the horses,
I'm very proud, because
I know when they feed a horse,
they will learn
to feed themselves.'
It's the first time
some of these kids
will ever get to be
on a horse,
and they watch
and they are really proud
when they watch their
older brother get on the horse
and they get very excited
and it is something
they really want to do
and become really good at.
On the Crow reservation,
I met Michelle Walking Bear.
She invited me
to come stay with her
and her family at their home
for a little less than a week
and, she said because
'I want you to see that...
I just want you to see
the daily life with horses.'
She goes, 'you know,
it's not all about
rodeos and parades,'
she goes, 'we just
live with the horses.'
They live about an hour
away from...
from the main town,
so when her kids
came from school,
this is what they did.
And I saw the horses
as their playmates.
And I saw that the horse
carried the dreams
and reflecting their dreams
and making those dreams
realities.
Back on the Yakima
Reservation,
they hold what's called
a 'Wild Horse Race'.
They take green horses,
the horses that have
never been ridden.
They have children do it
as well as adults.
There's usually
three people on a team
and their point is you have to
catch the horse,
saddle it and ride it
in shortest amount of time,
and these horses are
very wild.
But what I found
most interesting is that
this horse race
is a memorial horse race,
called the Heemsah Memorial
Horse Race
and has been going on
for over 20 years.
It was meant originally
for their family
to honor people that had died
that year in their family,
but over the years
anyone from the tribe
or anyone from the community
could come
and honor someone that
had died in that past year
for this race.
This is on the Yakima
Reservation
and something I learnt
when I was out there
that there is a problem
with wild horses.
And, the men there
told me that...
they said at some point
they had
over 20,000 wild horses and
what it ultimately was doing...
was devastating the land
and he said...
'any biologist, anyone
knows anything about the land
and that would not be me,'
he said,
'would look at this picture
and know that
it had been completely
devastated,'
and he said 'for the tribe,
it is very important,
because one,
this is their land,
two, this is the place where
they dig for medicine, roots...'
And he said and...
there's way too
many horses
and he goes, 'and also
you don't want to walk out
and see a lot of
starving horses running around,'
and he goes, 'and that's
what's happening,'
And he said to me
'this is what happens
when things are out of balance'
and he said,
'so even something as
powerful the horse
that represents, in my eyes
on my journey,
something really good
and when things are
out of balance,
it also causes problems.'
I'm going end here.
We have a special guest
tonight Leo Teton,
but before I bring him up,
I have a very short video
I want to show you of Leo
just to be able to bring you
to his home for a minute or so.
Up here on the stage
you get one Leo,
but at home
you get to see someone
very different
when he works with horses.
Leo Teton:
Come on! Come on!
( whistles )
Come on!
Come on...
keep coming.
Keep coming.
There you go.
Yeah. Yeah.
( applause )
So Leo, for those of us
who don't know,
tell us where you are from.
Well first of all, my...
my tribe is Shoshone-Bannock.
My mom is Shoshone,
my dad is Bannock.
We are one of the
bigger tribes in Idaho
and we are all horse people
there also.
They are spiritual horses
and they are kind to us and,
if we are kind to them,
they are kind to us.
We thank the
creator of all life
for bringing him,
the four-legged brother,
he is a brother to us,
so you can use him
in a good way.
We talk to horse, you know,
they understand us.
They are smarter than
us humans, you know.
Is it true,
because I've heard this
a lot of times, but were you
really put on a horse
before you could walk?
Would you say that's pretty--
You know... yeah,
because my dad had,
I've seen him put young kids on
and just lead them around
not give them the rein,
just lead them around,
even there's cradle boards,
you know, on the side,
my mom would ride and hang him
on the side of the horse
and lead them that way,
and they were these babies,
yeah,
and I still love them today
and I can't wait to get back
home to ride 'em, you know,
It's the first time
in the city here.
I'm not a city dude.
( audience laughing )
Talk to me about
working with horses,
just working cattle
with horses,
the daily life
you had growing up
the economic way of life,
your family,
what was that like?
What did that mean for you?
You know,
when my dad was growing up,
he had lot of horses,
he lived off the ranch,
lived off the land,
all of us guys did.
My dad was my mentor.
It's a lot easier now
than back in the day,
it was a lot rougher.
So the meaning of hard work
my dad taught me.
You know, riding horses,
you know, it makes me feel good,
growing up that way.
When I was out with you...
I got to go when they were
rounding up some horses
with him and
his brothers and
some other... other
family members
and what I noticed, pictures
like this,
we are out with
horses all day,
and then everybody
just sits around the fire
and they start talking
and people bring food
and they start laughing
and telling stories
and that's what I find
really special,
is that the social aspect
that surrounded this.
This is the time
when families got together,
and that's what I saw
with you.
Tell me a little bit
about that.
It takes a while for the cows
to get off the range.
We just got to bringing them
back off the range here
and we had some coffee on that
fire, we drink it up and...
And after that it was
a bunch of people,
we are just all a big family,
coming together
laughing and joking and...
but that was all part of
growing up, you know,
getting together after
the big shindig, you know,
like a buffalo hunt
or deer hunt.
Tell me about
the buffalo hunt,
what is means to you...
When we shot
this buffalo here,
we had a little ceremony,
you know.
It is always good to have a
little blessing for the animal
when you take his life,
that life is a life given.
That buffalo represents
strength, courage,
longevity, long life,
and we use all parts of his...
his hide, the skull,
the bones.
We don't leave nothing behind,
we take everything
and when we skinned him,
we give him that ceremony and...
his heart is still warm
when we gut him out
and that's
when I gave you that,
the taste of the blood
through his heart.
We got there and
after the hunt
they cut the heart out
and we all drank the,
the blood from the heart and..
why did we do that?
Well, it's a ceremonial,
ceremonial thing.
The buffalo represents
strength and courage
and long life
and spirituality,
and by doing that,
you know, you are gonna
live a long healthy life.
Also, you told me that
the meat from this,
when you did this hunt,
this was going to
-the elders in the tribe?
-Yeah, that meat
we took there...
because they can't hunt
no more.
We have to provide for them,
we just take care of them,
because they took care of us,
and it is
our turn to take care
of the elders.
Leo does a lot, you know,
he represents his tribe
in a lot of parades.
And you here,
you told me you are wearing
a war bonnet,
you have, you said it's
called a lance, correct?
That's a lance I'm holding,
yeah.
And you also have the war bridle
-tell me--
-And the war bridle
you got to be a pretty
experienced rider to
to have that...
it's made out of raw hide.
It's like a the back of the
sinew of the buffalo,
that's what that is and
how would you like to have
the cold bridle in your mouth?
You know,
and we had to run
a full circle,
there's a whole arena
right here
and we had to go
haul ass around
that whole thing there,
haul butt,
and he wanted to go
and I was holding him back,
and one time I broke it,
I broke that and I fixed it
real quick and go again,
you know, so that war bridle...
Like I said you gotta be
a pretty tricky rider to...
experienced rider
to mess with one of those.
You know,
that's back in the olden days,
clear back in 1800s,
that's what they used
when they went to war,
or off to steal
another tribe's horses,
you know,
that's what they did.
-And that's Indian Relay.
-Indian...
You know.
When I saw Indian Relay,
it's just breathtaking.
Now what I saw were people
that were just
extreme athletes
and this picture for me
sums up what I saw.
They were
flying with the horse
and everything,
everyone had told me...
when we work with horses, we
become one with horse as well.
They showed me that,
obviously.
Please tell me about
Indian Relay,
tell me about
your relationship in it
and what it means to kind of
pass this on to the youth?
Okay, the Indian Relay...
it started clear back
in early 1900s.
And what you see here
is Fort Hall.
And horses were coming out,
getting ready to run a race
and there's three guys
holding three horses.
When they will come out,
you'll see them.
Pretty good music, huh?
And that's the start
of the race right here,
and they'll go around and
they'll exchange again.
I've done this
for a lot of years
and I kind of retired from it.
And this is where they
exchange horses right here,
right in front of
the grand stand.
Now, next exchange
and I was holding over here
for one of my brothers.
I was a catcher.
And you got to catch
that horse
so he can jump
on to the next one.
Gets pretty exciting here.
How fast are some of these
horses coming in?
The horses, they come in
pretty quick like
25 miles an hour
and you got to jump off
to get on the next one.
But once they pick up speed
on last stretch
it's like 35 miles an hour.
And this is the last round.
Once they finish
the last round, they are,
they are winners.
So they are finishing
the track
right here to the finish line.
And it is pretty well-known
sport now.
It goes all over the world.
They are all over the place.
Tell me the history.
Where did,
when did Indian Relay start?
I've, I've heard that
it started in Fort Hall.
Yeah that's, that's true,
you know, it has.
It started right there
in Fort Hall,
that's where it originated,
this Indian Relay
and it's gone over worldwide.
It went viral, you know,
it's all over the place now.
You see these,
and that's me right there.
I'm 50-plus over now,
I'm an old man.
Tell me a little
bit of the future.
What's the future of horses?
What do you see with you
and your family
and your grandkids?
You know, I think right now,
I got lot of grandkids
growing up and
I'm just going to help them
to the best to my knowledge to
get them involved in
and working with horses,
and riding horses,
just by watching them,
taking them
to the horse racing
and maybe one day they will
carry it on to their kids,
you know and that's what
makes me feel good.
Erika Larsen:
Thank you guys for coming.
( applause )
( outro music )